prime minister you say you don't know
yet who is responsible for the damn
attack in Ukraine but if it turns out
that Russia is responsible what actions
will you take given that president
zielinski has called this bomb a called
this a bomb of environmental destruction
it's it's too early for us to say
definitively the cause of the attack our
military and security services are
currently investigating it but if it is
intentional it would represent an
unprecedented level of barbarism but
throughout this war Putin has
deliberately and as part of an active
strategy targeted civilian
infrastructure and civilian targets and
that's appalling and it's wrong no well
that's why not only are we supporting
Ukraine militarily we're providing
humanitarian support in advance actually
of this particular situation but also
we've been providing resources to those
who are responsible for bringing people
to justice for war crimes and others and
the UK is playing a leading role given
that you just said it was a tack of
accidented barbarism that it's an attack
on critical infrastructure does the
response need to step up from allies
well I think you've seen the response
has stepped up from allies the UK I'm
proud has played a leadership role in
providing UK with particularly Military
Support you'll you'll see that in the
coming weeks as Ukraine conducts its
counter-offensive but we were the first
country to provide main battle tanks the
first country most recently to provide
longer range weapons those will make a
difference but when it comes to holding
people to account it's important that we
support that work to gather evidence to
provide legal support and we're doing
that too all right promise let's go on
to your trip here as well as Ukraine AI
I want to talk to you about AI because
you have a very good understanding of
this issue but most of our viewers don't
so before we get into the regulatory
element of it can you explain to people
why there is as you put it an extent
existential threat if AI becomes more
intelligent than humans what's the worst
case scenario and how does it play out
I think when it comes to AI first of all
is to recognize that they're clearly are
benefits that we can realize for society
and our economy and particularly when
things like drug Discovery where we're
already starting to see those benefits
which I think everyone will welcome yes
but at the same time people will be
concerned when they hear from the
creators of the technology themselves
saying they worry about the existential
risk that AI poses
because the capability because people
are not quite sure of the full
capability of what AI will be able to do
over time the pace of that technology is
accelerating at a rate that people
didn't quite think was possible and
that's why it's important that we in
government put guard rails in place and
that's why I brought the companies
together in Downing Street a few weeks
ago to talk about what the appropriate
guard rails should be to make sure that
we can protect against those risks can
you it's confusing can you paint a
picture of the wrist well look I'm not
I'm not going to get into this business
of scaremongering people because I think
what people will say well hang on
there's a new technology which we don't
fully know yet what it's capable of
doing the creators themselves have
talked about risks on a scale on
Parallel with nuclear war and pandemics
and when people hear that they'll
rightly be worried about disagree no but
that's why I've actually been bringing
the companies together to talk about
right guard rails to put in place to
prevent those kind of things from
happening and that's why I think it's
important that we do that so very very
important and I think the public will
want to hear this so what you're saying
is if it's not regulated properly it
could be on the scale of equivalent to
nuclear risk it could kill humans we
have to monitor it I have to regulate it
it's absolutely right that we put guard
rails in place because the technology is
enormously powerful it's going to
reshape every aspect of our lives and
whilst that will bring many
opportunities and benefits it also poses
risks not just existential but also
risks of misuse of the technology and
that's why guard rails are important and
regulation your your AI task force chair
Matt Clifford Frank to me certainly
because he said that into we could be
just two years away from my eye being
able to kill many humans and the
situation could be terrifying I was
scared were you no so that there's a
range of opinions on how quickly the
technology will develop I think what is
clear is that there are very respected
people who are involved in developing
the technology who themselves are now
concerned that it's improving and
growing at such a pace that we need to
be more alert to these risks now look I
started talking about AI a couple of
years ago as Chancellor I invested in
scholarships for those from
disadvantaged backgrounds to do AI
Masters courses to strengthen our
research capability and provide
opportunity for people so I think I'm
well placed and I think the UK is well
placed to lead this conversation leading
me neatly into my next question which is
about regulation
um the truth is brexit has hurt us in
this hasn't it because you're locked out
of key forums between the EU and the US
where AI government plans are negotiated
while Britain's requests for similar
dialogue with Washington have been
rebuffed do you accept as a mid-sized
country competing with giant power
blocks of U.S China EU it's a struggle
for the UK to be hard and do you have to
shift the dial with Biden in these next
two days to call this trip a success I
actually have enormous confidence in our
country when it comes to this question
of AI because the facts speak to
themselves outside of the us we are the
leading Democratic AI Nation look at the
number of companies we have the amount
invested the quality of our researchers
and if you talk to the companies
themselves I think they would Echo much
of what I've said and that's why the UK
is the first and I think only place
where all the leading companies have
opened their International offices the
UK is the only place that has brought
them all together as I did in Downing
Street a few weeks ago so actually I
think we are well placed to lead and
shape this conversation on regulation
and when you talk to President Biden
about this tomorrow what do you need to
come out with so that we all say the
Prime Minister scored a win there we're
now we have our foot under the table on
AI what do you need what's the tangible
thing that we I think there are a few
things that people should be looking for
I think the first is look the US is our
closest trading partner but I always
want to strengthen that relationship so
I'm pleased to announce today 14 billion
pounds of investment that's going to
support thousands of jobs in the UK
that's really important next I want to
make sure that our trading relationship
our economic relationship evolves to
protect us against the new threats that
we face not just Sai but others as well
so expect to see me talking to them
expect to see me talking to President
Biden about Economic Security tomorrow
because I want to make sure that our
relationship can protect our citizens
and also continued support for Ukraine
these are all the topics we'll be we'll
talk about tomorrow I'm going to have to
move on because I haven't got much time
left so talking about the economy
promise to you promised economic
competence but the trust mortgage term
or it goes on under you hundreds of
deals were pulled from the markets last
week the average new two-year fixed
mortgage is at
5.72 Labor is leading the conservative
parties on polling when it come comes to
the economy you're the man that's meant
to sort this all out can you tell our
viewers when you think this terrible
situation might ease end of the year
2024 yeah first of all is I I know how
difficult it is and that's why when I at
the beginning of the year set out five
priorities for the country to halve
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and stop the boats the
first of those was to halve inflation
because it's inflation that's eating
into people's pay packets it's causing
challenges with the cost of living and
that's pushing up interest rates which
are harming people's mortgage bills what
I said is I want to halve inflation you
know I'm hopeful that we can do that by
the end of the year it's it's not easy
and when I set that Target out I knew
that it was ambitious because I knew
that it wasn't easy everyone actually
said oh that was too easy but actually
people are realizing now it's not it's
very sticky inflation and that's why we
have to stick to the plan and look
inflation is now starting to fall people
should have confidence that the plan is
working but we've got to stick to it
because that's how we'll ease the
burdens on the cost of living and bring
down in your trades two of your five
pledges con inflation half by the end of
the year the UK out of recession by the
end of the year if you fail on either of
them do you take personal responsibility
you don't blame the bank of England you
don't blame consumers you don't blame
businesses it's on you parsley because
they're your personal Prejudice of
course it's on me personally I'm the
Prime Minister I'm the person who set
out those five pledges to halve
inflation grow the economy reduce debt
cut waiting list and to stop the boats
and I intend to deliver on those and
when it comes to Growing the economy as
you mentioned we've already avoided the
recession that many predicted people are
upgrading our growth forecasts as we
speak I'm announcing 14 billion pounds
of investment into the UK which is going
to support thousands of jobs and just
this week I I managed to explain to the
country how we're progressing our boats
plan which means that this year you were
there Crossings into the UK down by
almost a fifth over the first five
months the plans are working but I'm not
complacent there's work to do with the
British public if you don't deliver it
by the end of the year that's on you
it's absolutely my responsibility I've
told the public to hold me accountable
they should be able to have politicians
who deliver what they say and that's
what I intend to do final question your
Chancellor last week said he was
prepared to risk recession if interest
rates rise to bring inflation down do
you agree with him yeah I think what the
chancellor was saying is that inflation
is the challenge that we must confront
obviously monetary policy interest rates
are a decision for the bank of England
so it wouldn't be right for me to
comment on that but look I set out five
priorities half inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
to stop the boats the first of those is
to halve inflation that's the thing that
I want to make sure we deliver because
that's what will happen in the long term
that is the best way to help British
families prime minister thank you so
much thank you for your time thank you